well how about this the day after the
dallas cowboys fell to two and four on
the season and there has been plenty of
criticism about the coaching staff
particularly on the defensive side of
the ball
we've got this from jane slater who has
been embedded with the cowboys on behalf
of nfl network and
she says cowboys players initially
bought into keeping things internal now
as they sit two and four the discontent
is leaking out on the coaching staff
quote totally unprepared they don't
teach they don't have any sense of
adjusting on the fly whoa end quote
another quote they just aren't good at
their jobs end quote well tell us what
you think
anonymous player who won't put your name
to it look i'm always always
yeah and not always i can't say i've
always been this way i've been in this
19 years as of november 1 with pft there
was a time when we would traffic in
anonymous opinion because it can be
interesting it can be controversial it
can gather clicks but ultimately i don't
know
how reliable any of it is
anonymous fact makes the journalism
world go round i don't want to turn this
into a journalism lecture but you know
people leaking facts without attaching
their name to it watergate never happens
if you don't have that
leaking opinion without attaching your
name is a tougher one to sell yeah
because i don't know who the guys are
that's right you got to tell me who if
it's if it's ezekiel elliot that feels
this way it's one thing right if it's
ben denucci the backup quarterback
who will probably never play a
meaningful down in his entire nfl career
if it's him i really don't care what if
it's the defensive tackle who's not
playing good and he's like getting
benched right and he's just mad like
you're right you don't right that's
that's the issue somebody who got chewed
out yesterday morning in the film room
for having a horrible game against the
cardinals he got chewed out yeah and as
soon as he's done he picks up his phone
and he starts texting these quotes that
i i need to know more to understand
whether or not to give them any
credibility or any credence but it is
interesting it is i mean we're talking
about it half hour into the show yeah so
there is
i don't want to say value but there's a
certain extent of rubber necking that
goes on when you think maybe there's a
car crash over there on the other side
of the road yeah well i mean definitely
first off i mean i think there already
was a car crash on the side of the road
when you talk about the dallas cowboys i
mean now it's like it's burning on fire
and we're all stopping and we're like
whoa look at all these police lights and
it's on fire like what the hell's going
on yeah it's it's it's been a disaster
first off jane slater i went to college
with her she's awesome she's connected
down there so anything she's reporting i
mean yeah she's being told by players
down there i certainly don't want to
discredit anything she's saying or doing
because i can promise you she's on top
of her game and what's being said there
but you're right there's always
discrepancies and things like that when
you hear
opinions and the other teams doing bad
but regardless it's just not a good look
all together when the when the play on
the field looks that way you know
there's this mismanagement of coaching
situations there's been turnover on you
know turnovers on the field there's been
blown coverages and mistakes on the
defensive side of the ball you know just
when you hear this
it just you know adds fuel to the fire
and you're right we don't know how true
it is but it's just a little alarming
when you're talking about a team that's
i think showing
signs of
dysfunction or maybe not being prepared
or whatever you want to say to some of
those quotes on the field on sundays and
you know when you hear things like this
sometimes it'll just help people maybe
think the perception is real or oh
that's why they're not playing well
they're not prepared all those things so
it's not a good look for mccarthy or the
cowboys
there's another element to this that i
find fascinating yeah because
you typically will have that tension in
a football organization
between the people responsible for
getting the most out of the talent and
the people responsible for finding and
acquiring the talent so
is it that the coaching staff isn't
properly developing and utilizing and
coaching the talent that is there that
is competent that is capable of winning
or is it that the people who are
responsible for getting the players
aren't doing a very good job and even
vince lombardi don schulich chuck noll
and bill belichick all on the same staff
couldn't do anything with it
that happens from time to time it
happens with losing teams what makes it
more
interesting here
ownership
are the people who yeah acquire the
players right
and and so and look i don't want to go
too far inside baseball but i'm not the
sports league that set up my own
in-house media conglomerate that embeds
reporters with these teams to cover
these teams while being paid by the
league
and
the network is partially owned by the
cowboys i just can't help but wonder
at one level
are the cowboys okay with this getting
out because
it takes some of the heat off of jerry
jones and at a higher level was it
instigated in any way
by the general manager i.e ownership of
the team so there's a lot of layers and
levels to this as to how this came to
light i mean it's possible it just
happened without any thought whatsoever
yeah but when you consider the fact that
it's coming from
the in-house league
media operation that is 132nd owned by
the cowboys and they've got an embedded
reporter there who's with the house
network you just you just and and and
you don't have a gm who can be at odds
with the coaching staff it's ownership
that would be at odds with coaching
staff you just you just can't help but
wonder
what what really may be going on yeah i
mean i i hear what you're saying i i
don't know if i i would necessarily you
know buy that that part of it uh not to
say that that hasn't happened before in
the history of the nfl or anything like
that but you know the jones ultimately
are responsible for this coaching stat
and that i mean that's their first issue
so i don't think they'd want to throw
more you know flames uh or fan to the
flames here as far as you know throw
more fans to the flames that you know
you don't want another fan on the flame
that they don't
throw more fans
out of control i think i might have
stumbled out of something there i like
that but yeah i think you know
with with that you know people were
already questioning mccarthy higher and
some of this stuff so i don't think the
jones family would want that out i think
the bigger thing here is again
it's the defensive coordinator and the
defense itself
right that doesn't mesh the coach and
what he coaches the players and who he
has they're not they don't schematically
fit together one was for a different
defense another now they're playing
another defense that doesn't work that
you can certainly blame
on the jones family no doubt about it
but um
it hasn't looked good we've seen like
we've talked about some bad management
of the games by mccarthy you know they
seem
bewildered on the field at points where
they're confused and everything like
that
and you know what's going to happen too
now is it's like all the stuff you heard
about mccarthy and green bay towards the
end those bad stories the bleacher
report article that tyler dunn wrote all
those things are going to start to get
they're going to start digging into that
crap again here that's what really is
concerning to me if i'm mike mccarthy or
the cowboys where people are going to
start to oh maybe that was real or maybe
we should call some other people in
green bay and they'll have some more
stories for us or whatever that may be
and i think that's what's going to be
annoying for dallas going forward
let's hear from mike mccarthy who
addressed the report yesterday in a
session with media members
well i mean i mean first off i mean i
haven't been part of any of those type
of discussions i i think like a lot of
things
uh when you when you hit
a part of your season or any challenge
where there is negativity out there you
know where and where it comes from and
who it comes from i mean that's that's
something that you know i've never
chased but i think you do have to
recognize it
and i just really go back to my first
meeting with the football team i've
always stated this to every team that
that i've that i've coached i think it's
important to handle things as men
i mean if you do have something to say
publicly that that is
of you know most important i think it's
important to say it to the individual
particularly in in in a group dynamic
setting
you know and i agree with that i mean it
does give us content and it does make
for some interesting discussion but you
prefer that people deal with these
issues directly and i think the litmus
test is the folks who are willing to
bring it up internally and have that
conversation
those are the ones who deserve the
credence and the ones who are going to
run the media and provide an anonymous
quote not attach their name to it we'll
assume it's the disgruntled second
string defensive lineman who got chewed
out in film study that morning
it really isn't something that needs to
be taken seriously but the problem is
it's out there it came up at his press
conference and it's now
something that people will be watching
because as you said chris the fumes of
that linger right from the latter days
of
mccarthy's tenure with the green bay
packers yeah and you know i i feel for
him it's a really tough spot you know he
took over a team with really high
expectations they wanted to change
things there in dallas and of course we
had coven 19 and it's really hard to
implement a new culture and all those
type of things when you're you know in
that that sort of circumstance there now
you lose your quarterback who's arguably
the best player on your team and i mean
i don't know the way it looked on monday
night i think it's very fair to make the
argument he is the best player in their
team and that they they even undervalued
him there in the dallas area as far as
how good he is we'll see where it goes
with with andy dalton but uh yeah
everything is concerning there right now
in dallas and mccarthy was not put in a
position to set up because of what was
going on in the world and then also was
not in a position to be successful
because of kind of
the jones and their roster building and
then the hiring of mike nolan and that
not making sense and meshing with the
roster you know that's tough that's
tough i don't know what they expected
there what kind of results they expected
to uh to get with with that type of
formula
yeah i agree with you and the the
pandemic really has affected a bunch of
teams differently but it makes it even
harder for the teams that have new
coaching staffs to hit the ground
running so the teams that have done well
with new coaching staffs i think we
should be even more impressed that
they've overcome the obstacles created
by the pandemic at least so far there's
still 11 weeks left in the season right
here is jerry jones from 105.3 the fan
he still does those two a week which is
good because he doesn't do the post-game
scrum that's one thing shireen williams
misses about the pandemic because after
every game jerry jones would
would stand there with
microphones and
and phones and and boom mics in his face
while he answers questions for a half
hour we don't get that anymore but we do
get him twice a week on 105 3 the fan in
dallas here he is talking about mike
nolan plus a little mccarthy on the
cowboys defensive scheme
i like the way that we came out last
night defensively and i thought that we
were had a good plan
for the skills of murray and what uh the
cardinals presented us i'll be very kind
of these aren't excuses but we're
sitting here talking about him early his
defense has had a very difficult time
with field positions where we've gotten
the ball early i'm okay with mike nolan
i am we're not just going to run a
scheme or run a scheme just because
that's the one we like i mean our job is
to make sure that we're putting players
in position to be successful now with
that we have to be accountability to
that into their skill set in how it all
fits together now they also have to be
accountable to the fact that
maybe a scheme or technique that they've
done in the past may be easier or they
liked it differently than what we're
asking them is but we feel it's in the
best interest of the team
well you know what mccarthy in a
roundabout way is making it clear that
it is about coaching it's not about how
good the players are that it's on them
to identify the right scheme implement
the right scheme and yeah that's what
coaching is yep i remember when mike
zimmer had
a conversation with me
i think the year he got the job in
minnesota the light finally went off for
me that it's not about what your scheme
is it's about who your players are
and you take who your players are and
yes some of them fit what you want to do
but you have to adjust and adapt
once you figure out what they do well
what they like to do what they don't do
well that's good coaching i remember
when hugh jackson was with the raiders
darren mcfadden had been disappointing
what did hugh jackson do
say what you will about his time with
the browns this is back when it looked
like things were maybe going to work out
for you he goes to darren mcfadden he
says what plays do you like to run yeah
it's that simple right right it's about
understanding and having that
relationship with each of your players
where you know what they're good at you
know what they're not good at you put
them in position to do the things they
can do you don't ask them to do the
things they can't do you work on them to
address their flaws and you see if maybe
you can take something from the can't do
category and slide it over while i try
not to move my microphone to the can-do
category
i that's coaching yeah and the way that
mccarthy just explained it it's like
okay mike you got the players it's on
you it's on you to turn it into
something
and it's pass fail and so far
you know but for pulling a rabbit out of
their butts against the falcons they'd
be one in five yeah no i mean i hear you
it's not good that way now you know hey
offensive line not good all those things
the one thing i'll say with respect to
mccarthy he just he'll never throw his
players or anything like that under the
bus he really won't he was phenomenal
about that in green bay with always kind
of taking the heat and he's got to do
better and do all that stuff too and you
know i hear what jerry jones is saying
the defense has been put in some tough
spots there was some good things they
did
last last uh monday night this past
monday night in the game i mean kyla
murray
you know he had a hard time finding open
receivers and getting completions uh but
yeah still at the end of the day there
were some big plays and they never made
a big stop in big moments and that's
kind of been the whole year for them you
know that you can coach i get that you
want to adapt and everything like that
makes sense i get that but i think with
the the story on the defensive side of
the ball is
you know there's only mike nolan coaches
a certain way this is what he does this
is what he knows so yes he can change
within those limits of okay i play and
coach defense like this but when those
players don't even fit within those
limits
that's when now you're asking the
defense quarter hey can you run another
defense that you've never run before
ever in the history we know we hired you
to run the other defense but you know we
messed up and gave you the wrong players
so can you run a defense you've never
coached before you know that's what
they're doing and that's to me where i
don't give a crap who you are you know
that's you can't overcome that you know
didn't you now you're asking the coach
to be totally different reinvent himself
and you know the only guy i've ever
really seen be able to do that to where
it's oh we're a 3-4 team and then the
next year we're a 4-3 team is the evil
genius up in new england i mean he's the
only guy i've ever known to see to be
able to do that so
uh that's where i would say it's not
fair
uh and mike nolan's trying to take it
like a man there but but realistically i
don't think he's in the best spot there
all the way with him and his coach's
staff
one of the best things about the cowboys
being coached by mike mccarthy as the
games go poorly mike mccartney
an agent with a verified account on
twitter gets a lot of heat from cowboys
fans because he's not doing a good job
with the team that's right that's
hilarious and mike mccartney
has fun engaging with these cowboys fans
you think he's mike mccarthy and then
they become apoplectic at the fact that
he's responding to tweets during the
game because they still think it's mike
mccarthy it's great it's great you need
to need to follow mike mccartney so you
can see the fun that he has with cowboys
fans as mike mccarthy flails during a
cowboys game hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports